it's great to welcome Pavlina Chernova
back to the program she's an associate
professor of economics and director of
the economics program at Bard College we
are today going to talk about modern
monetary theory Pavlina this is
something many people in my audience
over the last 6 to 12 months have been
increasingly asking me to talk about and
I've been reading about it now for
several months let's start sort of at
the at the very beginning modern
monetary theory is modern when compared
to what in other words it's a
counterpoint to what sort of default
economic theory well it's a counterpoint
to the theory that says that money
somehow emerges out of barter the
anthropological record shows that there
has never been such a thing where
society is somehow spontaneously find
some common medium of exchange and this
is the stuff that we teach even children
in the you know in school but so modern
monetary there is not that modern at all
but what we say is that the emergence of
money is always linked to some authority
to some state modern state to
priest-king or somebody who's able to
impose taxes or dues or fees on its on
his or her subjects and then determine
how those taxes will be paid so modern
monetary theory has this historical
aspect to it that correct the main
narrative that money somehow emerges out
of markets but fast forward to the
present day
modern monetary theory focuses on one
very important aspect of the modern
monetary system and that is that the
currency that you and I use we carry in
our wallets the dollar is a public
monopoly it is a creature of the state
in a very literal sense only the
government and its institutions
can issue the currency that we all use
and this though a simple observation has
profound implications for policy so
let's go back and sort of retail for
people who may not be familiar with this
sort of barter origin story of money as
we know it and as and you can correct me
if I'm wrong but as the story goes there
was a time before money where in
communities you would have someone who
produced bread and someone else who
produced I don't know who had chickens
or whatever the case may be and the
person who had bread might need chickens
but they might need something else and
very quickly it became difficult to
figure out well how many loaves of bread
equate to one chicken but if you
actually need shoes do you need half a
chicken but if you have bread what do
you do so as the story goes there was a
currency that was created which had a
value that made exchange far easier and
as as that story is told it does not
really necessitate anything like the
Federal Reserve or a government or a
king but what you're saying is that that
story we've been told is not really true
correct that's right so what virtually
everybody is taught in school is that we
produce yes milk eggs chicken the Tetra
we then have to trade with one another
and we have this paradox I don't know
whether you will need my eggs but I do
need your milk and but I need the
neighbours product and so there is this
problem of coordination I might not need
the stuff you're selling but you may
need the stuff I'm selling so the story
goes
but somehow we decide you know we put
our heads together and we say hey this
is a difficult problem that's barter
let's just figure out a unit a medium of
exchange to trade you know you give me
some coin for my eggs and then I give it
to the neighbor for you know for the
wool then the story goes and this is
sort of the incorrect historical story
the story goes that people figure out to
use something shiny something precious
usually gold because it has some
intrinsic value arguably and an eventual
the state comes in and observes the gold
deposits takes over that money that
emerged from private interactions and
then started debasing the currency so
actually in the conventional story the
state is the villain in terms of how
money emerges the story that we tell
that we believe is supported by the
historical anthropological record and I
should say only economies economists
tell the barter story other sciences
they do not tell this story but the one
that we have uncovered is that actually
the state is present from the beginning
and I really am using the state in very
broad terms that there is an authority
there is some king priests shaman
religious authority that tells its
subjects you have to pay dues taxes to
the gods to me that you can't escape
they are not reciprocal what's the
purpose of this of course is to bring to
the church you know chickens eggs some
some real stuff that's the reason for
the text to provision in a way the
priest or the church or the king but in
the act of imposing the tax then that
authority says how the tax will be paid
and suddenly that thing becomes valuable
and society begins using it as a common
exchange a common unit of exchange so
there have been very many forms of money
way before gold thousands of years
before gold that are not intrinsically
valuable feathers cowrie shells you name
it but because in the cultural context
of the time that was one way to pay that
tax obligation society suddenly started
using that thing as their medium of
exchange but I think what would be an
interesting example to give is for
example looking at societies that never
had use for currencies so if you look at
the
colonies in Africa they were not they
were not organized in a way to sell cash
crops or to have wage labour and
suddenly the colonial governors start
coming in and one way in which they can
extract resources from their colonies is
to impose attacks in British pounds
French francs now a tribe or a community
that has never used the British pound
has no use for it but suddenly the
colonial governor says no this is the
tax that you're gonna pay and either the
only source of the British pound so what
do I need to do to satisfy the tax to
the colonial governor I have to deliver
my goods my resources to that governor
to obtain the currency I didn't need
before to satisfy that tax and this is
how cash crops emerged wage labour
emerges in some societies that
previously were not organized this way
so what I'm suggesting is that virtually
in every context there is some authority
that says how you pay your dues and that
becomes money of that society one of the
big sort of repercussions as as those
who maybe are not followers of modern
monetary theory interpret the disconnect
between a country's ability to produce
currency and it not being connected to
some material of intrinsic value like
gold for example is that while yes the
government could physically print more
money as is often the term that this has
the impact of making each unit of
currency each dollar to take the United
States less valuable and thus it causes
inflation so that there is really no
advantage to just printing more money in
order to improve the economy talk about
the basis of that belief first and
foremost well it comes again from this
barter story the story is that the
government came in assert power over the
gold mines and instead of minting the
gold coins that society previously
minted for itself
it started debasing it it started
chipping it away its
mixing it with other non precious metals
and eventually the story goes the
government decided well forget about it
we're not gonna use gold we're just
going to use paper certificates that are
backed by gold but eventually the
government decides well why should we
back these paper certificates at all
let's just use paper money and this is
the source of this notion that the
government had no intent to maintain the
value of the currency they just wanted
to inflate away its value in order to be
able to spend in excess of the gold
deposits that again is not part of the
historical record first money it from
the very beginning was virtual money
the very first units of money that we
discover I'm markings on clay tablets
clay tablets do not have any inherent
value so they are simple records of what
you were saying earlier equivalence is
between products how much barley is
worth how much wheat how much we can
exchange for how much gold that was the
first form of money they have virtual
records and then when you look through
history of time gold standards have
existed but they are not the norm so in
the modern world you know governments
and societies periodically get on and
off gold but they are not the norm so
there's nothing inherently inflationary
about a society that is using non gold
money now in the modern world
as you say we have paper currency that
comes from modern central banks that the
central banks were indeed created to
give government's flexibility and
spending to deal with major crises you
know so at the turn of the century you
know we we had the emergence of very
many central banks and they are they
hold the power of the purse for the
government in a way so it is true that
we created central central banks that
were the monopolies sure
of currencies to be able to provision
the government financially when you need
to deal with depression when you have a
war when you have other policy
priorities in the modern 20th century
there's nothing inherently inflationary
about that there are certain conditions
that can make spending inflationary and
they deal a lot with the productivity of
the economy not simply issuing currency
that's a good place I think actually to
pause and the next step the next part
that we'll talk about is what would the
implications be for government policy if
indeed modern monetary theory was to be
adopted so we'll pause there with
Pavlina churn Ava she's an associate
professor of economics at Bard College
and we'll continue our conversation with
her we're continuing our conversation
with Pavlina churn Ava who's an
associate professor of economics and
director of the economics program at
Bard College we established in part one
of the interview Pavlina some of the
arguably false notions about how money
sort of came to exist in societies and
we started to talk about modern monetary
theory where I want to pick it up with
you is if indeed we were to agree or it
might not even require agreement but if
the reality were that the government
could just create money and use it in
different ways to stimulate the economy
what would be the implications of that
maybe within the United States at the
national level what things could be done
that right now are not done because of
this idea that if you just start
printing more money you're going to
create hyperinflation alright so let me
stress that we believe that we live in a
modern money world it's not that we need
to adopt it we already are there and we
have many examples to illustrate this
take take the 2008 great financial
crisis we didn't call China or tax away
the dollars from the population to
provide funding for the financial sector
when we appropriate budgets for going
into war we
don't wait to find the money that is
precisely the power of the purse
whenever we have policy priorities they
are funded no questions asked the
primary example I think is the current
legislation the tax legislation under
the Trump administration it is very
clear that this is the policy priority
we don't need to wait to find the money
to provide this this great benefit to
corporations or high net income
households
so we already live in this world but we
are told continually that money is a
scarce resource we have ample evidence
to the contrary but people are sold a
bill of goods in the sense that oh gee
you know the deficit is increasing the
debt is out of control we did do XY and
Z but now we have to pay for it and we
will pay for it by cutting variety of
programs this is a false narrative
financially we can afford whatever
policy priorities we have the question
is do we have the real resources to
satisfy those needs if I were to sort of
lift the veil over money to have an
honest conversation with the population
about what the policy priorities are if
if we refuse to believe the lie that
there is no money then then you will see
very different in my opinion Policy
Priorities I think and generally in
general people believe a much more
progressive agenda they like their
Social Security they don't want to
sacrifice their Social Security they
would like to have affordable health
care they would like to have affordable
education they would like to have good
infrastructure we have countless of
things that people value that they count
on and would like to have but somehow
are convinced they must sacrifice
because the government has run out of
money and this is really the narrative
we need to to change to be able to do
the things that people want them so for
someone who is operating under the
understanding that if you do just print
more money to pay for what what some on
the right leg to call free stuff for
people that the money becomes worth less
and less over time because there's more
in circulation let's apply it to a
specific example you mentioned health
care right so we can have a debate over
what would it cost for a single-payer
health care system let's assume that we
can agree on what that would be maybe
it's $8,000 per person per year the
number doesn't really matter right and
what modern monetary theory would
suggest is that you don't need to find
that money elsewhere in the budget or
necessarily tax people to obtain that
money that you could basically just
create that money and in the modern
world whether it requires the physical
printing of it or basically just
crediting it virtually to the
government's coffers that that could be
done and we could pay for everyone's
health care and that there would be no
negative repercussions elsewhere in the
economy inflation included is that more
or less what mmt indicates not quite
there are real repercussions of the
policies that we employ but they are
real they are not financial so what we
are saying is that financially yes we
can afford to pay for our universal
health care financially the resources
there but the difficult questions are
where will the money go if the money
goes to employ unemployed resources
unemployed nurses doctors to build
community clinics provide services that
are not there then the issue of new
money is connected to the issue of some
real value production so it's not really
a free freebie for people I mean it
takes work it takes resources to be able
to do universal health care they may be
negative repercussions currently
enormous amount of money goes towards
the private insurance industry that has
enormous overhead costs we know that
Medicare has very small overhead cost by
comparison they
we'll be some repercussions there
somebody's going to lose their job so it
is not clear that this program will be
inflationary because it's not
necessarily a net new expenditure it
might displace existing expenditure and
these are the questions we need to be
asking how much production how much
employment how much health provisioning
have we accomplished but people are
focused on the money we are running out
of money we got to take it from here to
give it here and that is not how it
works let's talk about debt and deficit
a little bit because we know that it's
become such a political tool that is
used it's very often that you see
particularly Republican elected
officials oppose increases to the debt
that would be connected to funding
social programs or ideas proposed by
Democrats but at the same time they seem
to have no problem increasing the
year-to-year deficit if it's for tax
cuts for the rich or whoever else it is
that they want to provide some kind of
financial benefit to is that entire
conversation a red herring in other
words does the debt matter it depends on
what you know what you're trying to
accomplish the debt and the deficit are
just simply accounting results of what
we have done yes they matter in terms of
how they were incurred so if we had a
great deficit as a consequence of giving
enormous tax cuts to the top and that
did very little for the economy yes it
matters it no but if we incurred
expenditure that produced employment
investment etc then yes it matters as
well it's just you have to look at the
real reserve results what doesn't matter
is its size in and of itself so a lot of
people are believed there's a magical
number of the deficit or the debt beyond
which some terrible things will happen
to the economy in this sense modern
money says that this is totally the
wrong thing to be looking at the first
thing that we like to stress and this is
kind of an important point
the phobia of deficit spending needs to
go away
the deficit is an absolute necessity for
the economy the reason is that the
deficit is simply the difference between
what government spends and what it taxes
back and if the government said spent a
hundred billion dollars but only taxes
eighty back the 20 billion dollars
remain in the economy that is savings
those are net savings in the private
sector so this is a simple accounting
identity this is a simple simple math if
government spends more than it takes
back the different stays in our pockets
and that's called our savings we like to
save we like to put away money for
retirement for college education etc so
because we the private sector like to
save the deficit has to exist the
question is where did the money go
whose pockets did it fill did it go
again all the way to the top where it
was maybe invested in the stock market
or did it go in the pockets of firms
intrapreneurs households that are trying
to meet their daily demands and
essentially improve their standard of
living there's no question that if our
elected officials at least at the
national level learned about mmt
understood it and and maybe adopted it
that we would have a very very different
way of governing do you see any evidence
that that is starting to happen that it
could happen I think that they they
operate on the principles of mmt again
the current tax discussions revealed
that the Republicans never took
seriously the debt and the deficit
whenever they want their policy
priorities the debt and deficit is not
just secondary it's it's it's not at all
at the point of discussion but Democrats
have to change because they continue to
harp on this debt deficit problem so we
number one the tax discussion showed
that this is a very
critical attitude that the debt and
deficit really don't matter in terms of
their size what matters is what we do
with the expenditure and what I would
like to see is more people begin to
think this way because then we will be
asking the questions have we really
produced full employment do people have
decent jobs decent incomes do we have
the investment that we need for our
economy do we have inflation
you know mmt will be concerned about
inflation at full employment or even
before there these are the real
questions not the size of the debt and
the deficit so I believe that the
current political environment operates
certainly on the Republican side
operates on the principles of mmt but
the rhetoric is used to undermine
privatize other important programs we've
been speaking about modern monetary
theory we're going to continue covering
it and we've been speaking with Pavlina
Chernova who's associate professor of
economics and director of the economics
program at Bard College thanks so much
for joining us again my pleasure